Jennifer thank you so much for joining
me today uh tell me a little bit about
your chess upbringing um so I first
learned how to play chess in chess club
at school um my parents told me I should
go so I went and I liked it at first
just because if you won they would give
you little key chains little chess
keychains so I I really lik that and
then eventually I started competing um
so I don't think I had a very like
strictly like oh we should play chess
like like ever since I was young I just
kind of did all sorts of different
things and chess was one of them and
eventually I just kind of got a little
better at chess so it was like oh if you
get better you have to put more time
into it so that's just kind of what
happened with me and then um I so I kind
of feel like I just grew up playing this
game did you spend a lot of time as a
kid uh studying from books or were you
already at the time where things were
available online so you spend more time
training online when I first started I
would just do tactic books like puzzle
books honestly the main way I trained my
whole life was just puzzles like I that
was the main thing I like to do so I
whether or not I should have focused on
other things I just really liked it so
um eventually it was like last growing
up there was like tactics trainer was
really popular in chess.com so I would
just do so much tactics trainer every
single day but that was how I kind of
worked on the game for a very long time
very nice and you won this Championship
two times so far and you're defending
um Champion how uh do you feel about
getting into this tournament like I know
you mentioned you've struggled with um
you know you're a full-time student
you're going to Harvard how are you able
to still find time for chess and getting
ready for the tournament uh I never
really know how to answer these kind of
questions because I think I'm constantly
trying to get better and learning like I
don't think I'm the best at handling it
I I definitely it comes in waves like
last year I think I did an all right job
but also at the same time last year
there were times where I slept like 3
hours a night cuz I was writing a paper
you know before a game so it's always
something I'm working on like this year
I have to take a midterm at the
tournament um I'm being proctored by a
TD like after the game so I don't know
how it's going to go um but I'm trying
my best so we'll see you've been able to
manage things really well last year and
and you're always very focused when
you're playing a tournament do you also
uh so you go to school but do you are
you able to combine uh also a healthy
lifestyle so that you're able to have
enough energy to deal with all of these
tough situations in your life yeah um
it's really important for me to like
personally like stay active and also be
social like I really love spending times
with like my friends and my roommates so
um that's something I value a lot so
sometimes when you have to pick between
This and like studying that's also its
own challenge but I you don't need me to
talk about okay no but what about um in
school besides school are you involved
in any projects like any clubs um at
school anything else that you're doing
besides studying and chess yeah so I was
part of a lot of different um like
extracurricular like pretty professional
organizations and a lot of different
other clubs on campus over the last
couple of semesters and um so something
I'm doing a little bit different this
semester is I'm putting a lot of it on
the back burner and mainly just focusing
on school and like try to do some chess
just because I felt like I was being
stretched very thin but you know I
learned a lot of different things from
my experiences in those organizations so
that's just that's that's for like the
future for whatever career I end up to
it are you still deciding on which
career you might be going um after
graduating um yeah I yeah it's it's
still in the process for Recruitment and
a lot of different other things but yeah
like I I think I changed my mind quite a
few times over the last few years so so
we'll see how it goes how many more
years do you have I'm a junior right now
so this year and then last year next
year sounds good well I hope you've been
able to balance everything well and
you're going to do well during this
tournament I'm looking forward to seeing
your games thank you so much Jennifer
and good
[Music]
luck